avec nous Claude Meunier auteur comédien
que vous connaissez bien merci d'être là
Claude Meunier et au téléphone avec nous
son ami j'allais dire son frère Marc
Messier Marc merci d'être avec nous
c'est un plaisir Patrice salut Claude
premier tour de table Claude Meunier
jouer avec cet homme-là est-ce que il
était parce que est-ce qu'il était dans
la vie privée ce que nous on a pu
connaître c'est-à-dire on trouve pas
beaucoup de défauts à cet homme là
pas des défauts qui c'était
un grand compagnon de travail c'était
très agréable de travailler avec Michel
coté c'était un grand plaisir de le
côtoyer il faisait partie de notre
famille on connaît Michel depuis
tellement longtemps c'est comme
c'est un peu de nous autres qui meurent
aujourd'hui qui disparaissent une partie
de tout ce qu'on a fait quand on était
jeune on faisait partie d'un coup d'un
même courant à l'époque des années au
début des années 80 après ça on s'est
suivi au théâtre à la télévision
c'est un morceau nous autres qui
disparaît puis c'est un acte
excessivement attachant excessivement
sensible une personne unique Michel Côté
je pense vraiment
Marc je disais un frère évidemment il y
a l'aventure de Brou mais au-delà de ça
comme a dit Claude Meunier vous avez
grandi d'une certaine façon ensemble
professionnellement alors vous étiez
très proche Marc oui nous on s'est
connus au début de la vingtaine moi j'ai
écouté
presque 50 ans
si on a fait des tournées on a beaucoup
joué on a joué sur scène et tous les
comédiens vont vous dire quand on joue
avec quelqu'un sacré des liens encore
plus forts parce qu'on voit
on voit la la vulnérabilité puis la
sensibilité des gens non non je suis
très triste aujourd'hui c'est une
journée difficile mais faut penser
pardon je pense
il avait l'humilité des grands il avait
l'humilité des grands il était
perfectionné ce oui ça avait l'air
naturel ces rôles là Claude Meunier mais
vous vous l'avez vu dans la petite vie
entre ils travaillaient là
perfectionnisme et c'était un plaisir de
travailler avec lui était toujours au
maximum mais il y avait une façon de
jouer Michel que peu de comédiens ont
été tellement investi dans ces rôles il
était tellement perfectionniste maniaque
il allait au bout puis il était très
exigeant pour lui-même très exigeant il
voulait toujours avoir la meilleure
réaction possible avec le public c'est
un grand grand comédien c'est un grand
comique c'était un exemple d'un travail
mais c'était tellement plaisant de de
jouer avec lui puis c'est quelqu'un de
remarquable il y avait quelque chose de
de d'une équipe transcendait ses rôles
il faisait à peu près à peu près un des
meilleurs acteurs de composition qu'on a
au Québec on a besoin de faire des
compositions créer des personnages de
toutes pièces mais malgré tout même sur
leur connaissait pas il y avait toujours
l'arme de Michel Côté à travers ces
rôles vraiment et il y avait quelque
chose de particulier puis il y avait une
espèce d'intelligence qui émanait de ce
gars
vous l'avez tellement côtoyé souvent
jouer avec lui racontez-moi
oh non c'était Michel comme dit Claude
il y a tout à fait raison c'est un
talent exceptionnel c'est un gars qui
était perfectionniste effectivement
c'est un gars qui voulait prenait jamais
le monde pour acquis le public et c'est
un gars qui voulait toujours aller plus
loin puis
non c'est un grand grand comédien moi je
l'ai vu jouer Brou en anglais
puis tu sais bon Michel vient dans le
mot au lac Saint-Jean qui n'est pas la
meilleure place pour apprendre l'anglais
on s'entend et ils sont son personnage
de pointu qui jouait
marchait écoute le plafond vert à
Toronto ça c'est j'étais vraiment
vraiment impressionné non c'est un gars
qui avait comme du Claude il y avait
quelque chose d'unique beaucoup d'armes
beaucoup de cœur et
beaucoup de charisme toutes les choses
qui se
portent que tu as pas et lui avait et ce
grand respect du public que Claude
Meunier vous l'avait dit il était
conscient que de l'autre côté du tube
dans le cas de la télévision dans la
salle de spectacle au cinéma il y a du
public et voulait donc comme vous avez
dit être à son meilleur
ouais mais Michel effectivement de se
soucis là de toujours donner le maximum
moi j'ai joué avec les gars j'ai joué
avec Marc j'ai joué avec Michel mais
puis je peux vous dire que quand on est
à côté de autres on sent que on sent
qu'il y a un travail de tous les
instants de tous les instants puis j'ai
vraiment vu des comédiens habités autant
des rôles des grands comédiens je me
parle de Michel on parlera de marque à
une autre fois
le côté aussi dramatique parce qu'il
avait un sens du rythme vous on l'a
beaucoup souligné c'est devenu un cliché
mais c'est vrai pour faire rire il faut
qu'on soit impeccable dans le rythme il
l'avait aussi pour le drame marque ouais
mais c'est ça c'est que la comédie puis
le drame en fait ça prend un rythme qui
est celui de la vie que Michel c'est un
fait observateur puis il était super bon
en dramatique lui se sentait plus à
l'aise il disait tout le temps ma zone
de confort c'est la comédie mais quand
il jouait des rôles dramatiques qui
étaient merveilleux aussi et moi je
disais tout le temps pourquoi tu joues
pas plus dramatique qui est puis je le
trouvais extraordinaire mais c'est un
gars aussi qui avait
parla tout le monde sait c'est pour ça
que les gens aiment tant c'est parce que
c'est un gars qui faisait pas de
différence entre les gens qui parlent à
tout le monde qui étaient près des gens
c'est un ami
effectivement généreux vraiment et ça je
suis content aujourd'hui de voir toute
l'amour pour lui
finalement tu reçois beaucoup je pense
c'est un homme de famille Michel c'est
un homme il y en a beaucoup sa famille
c'est ce qu'elle peut triste parce que
il se préparait à penser plus de temps
avec sa famille il y en a pas assez
beaucoup mais il était près de ses
enfants c'est petits enfants puis Marc
m'a déjà parlé de ça qu'il était très
proche de sa famille et puis là ils sont
en ligne justement pour être plus
présent c'est un peu triste
évidemment puis c'était un gars on
sentait ça son attachement très
affectueux en fait très très effectué
moi c'est c'est ça qui est un peu
difficile aussi parce que Michel
avait-il dizaine lui-même là qui voulait
prendre sa retraite et tout ça et puis
il voulait le stress du jeu le
fierté il disait bon puis il voulait
dans sa poursuite du bonheur
changer un peu de vie et il s'apprêtait
à faire ça voyager avec Véronique puis
pensez beaucoup de temps avec ses
petits-enfants et c'est ça qui est qui
est triste aussi que ça soit arrivé à ce
moment-là c'est belle la seule fois dans
sa fille ou qui est vraiment manquait de
timing
[Rires]
merci de nous avoir parlé chez qui c'est
normal vous avez énormément de peine et
on vous comprend merci beaucoup Claude
Meunier également merci de nous avoir
parlé à bientôt merci merci
finalement au cinéma Louis José Aude
bonsoir
autre génération vous vous avez c'est
fascinant parce qu'il y a joué votre
père dans deux films un et deux
racontez-moi d'abord les premiers
contacts avec lui comment ça s'est passé
très très chaleureux moi j'étais comme
vous êtes une génération qui connaissait
beaucoup beaucoup c'est à dire que avec
les gros zimbres et des trucs comme ça
j'étais parfaitement offrir de son
travail et quand je l'ai rencontré
j'étais en admiration et j'ai vraiment
pas été déçu comme genre presque Marc
qui disait un petit peu plus tôt c'est
quelqu'un qui était vraiment au même
niveau avec tout le monde c'est
quelqu'un qui appelait le respect mais
qui ont donné énormément c'est quelqu'un
de très respectueux très respecté puis
très respectueux la première fois qu'on
s'est rencontré il était très très
chaleureux avec moi et m'a pris dans ses
bras il m'a assis sur ses genoux pour
une séance de photos puis il m'a presque
chatouiller on était très très
confortable avec l'autre assez
rapidement dans nos rapports puis
c'est vrai qu'il parlait beaucoup de sa
famille on a fait deux films où on
jouait père et fils lui et moi et donc
les conversations sur le sujet
revenaient beaucoup qui me parlaient
beaucoup de Charlie Maxime comment il
était fier
ça me touchait de voir cet homme-là qui
avait un cabine super Michel il y avait
une façon il y a une prestance c'était
un homme fier un homme très élégant et
qui était
une présence vraiment très très forte
mais qui était en même temps très très
des gens très très doux très sensible
très affectueux ce qui fait que les
jeunes les maîtres comme les moins
jeunes les femmes les met comme les
comme les hommes les mecs je pense qu'il
pouvait autant discuter avec le Premier
ministre qu'avec
avec l'opérateur de machinerie lourde
c'était vraiment quelqu'un qui qui était
proche de tout le monde et puis c'était
pour moi
une grande chance de travailler avec lui
vous vous êtes un exemple aussi de
quelqu'un qui travaillait aussi parfois
de façon maniaque sur des phrases sur le
rythme et tout ça jouer avec quelqu'un
comme ça et lui aussi c'est important
que ça fonctionne j'imagine que ça a dû
cliquer ça a déjà extraordinaire là
dessus
complètement ces textes extraordinaire
c'est 1000 goduro qui avait eu l'idée de
nous réunir ce qui est le réalisateur
scénariste de pas enfler et moi j'ai
trouvé vraiment beaucoup de plaisir
parce que mais comme vous dites c'est
quelqu'un qui on parle de les membres de
Brou là c'est vraiment pas n'importe qui
c'est quelqu'un qui avait un très très
grand timing comics un grand maître du
rire à mes yeux et de me retrouver à
échanger avec lui donner la réplique
c'était mon d'une grande chance que j'ai
eu c'est choisir il y a personne c'était
d'ailleurs le meilleur accordeur de
blague que je rencontrais dans ma vie
mes blagues de taverne de newfee et
autres
c'est quelqu'un qui m'a fait rire
beaucoup beaucoup dans ma vie on sait
que c'est des longues journées de
tournage au cinéma et l'amour qu'on lui
rend aujourd'hui ça témoigne bien de ce
qu'il était il était proche des gens
comme vous dites n'importe qui le
Premier ministre le le le dernier des
machines est le l'autre qui rencontrait
dans un restaurant il était pareil avec
tout le monde quelqu'un parlait de Guy
la flore ce matin il y a ce côté là
aussi d'un personnage qui ne change pas
de personnage justement il est lui-même
je pense que les gens étaient jamais
déçu de le rencontrer on sait qu'il y
avait jamais de mauvaise journée puis il
faut comprendre aussi quand on tombe des
films comme ça on se voit à des heures
on fait des longues journées on passe
beaucoup de temps ensemble donc quand
les gens qui ont travaillé avec lui
disent que c'était un homme qui avait
une bonne amie une bonne humeur
naturelle c'est pas surfait parce que
c'est
le dernier tournage qu'on a fait de
faire un flic 2 il y avait je crois
après 66 67 ans puis on se retrouvait
comme ça des journées de pluie à 5h45
puis il était il était il était
tellement heureux d'être là
au niveau professionnel c'est de voir
tout le bagage qui avait tout le
parcours qui avait derrière lui
peut-être aussi heureux de se retrouver
sur un plateau de tournage puis de
côtoyer des l'équipe les comédiens
c'était une grande inspiration monsieur
magnifique je l'aime ais beaucoup mais
merci de nous avoir parlé Louis José
haute passera quelqu'un qui est autant
en théâtre à la télévision qu'au cinéma
laisse ça marque dans les trois domaines
aujourd'hui on peut voir l'étendue de
son travail
l'ampleur de son travail aussi tout son
tout son côté versatile tout ce qui
était capable de faire ça polyvalence
quand on voit les
biographies sur lui tranquillement
aujourd'hui c'est fantastique de voir ça
merci beaucoup de nous avoir parlé oui
je vous ai dit merci à la prochaine au
revoir